Muslim.
And then
[Silence]
So we have a story here narrated
or collected by half of im Muslim.
And this story is before the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam made hij when the
mushri of started to not only become
very hostile but they became murderous.
They became murderous.
we have one of the biggest enemies of
the prophet sallall.aii Wasam and the
Muslim and the companions who is known
mo to most people as Abu Jah. Abu Jah
jah in the Arabic language is
ignorance and Abu is usually a term of
respect. Abu fan
his was never Abu Jah to start with. His
name is Amarbin Hishem. He comes from
a lineage of
basically tribal royalty
and he was referred to as Abul Hakim.
That was his original kuna that people
referred to him as Abul Hakim. I would
heckim would translate to
one of incredible
wisdom and one of incredible justice and
fairness. You say alakim is someone who
is not only knowledgeable but someone
who is very wise and very just and fair.
So he was always referred to as Abul
Hakim and his name is Amb Hisham and he
is originally from the tribe of Kinana
which meets with the lineage of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam. He comes
from very high esteem and lineage and he
was as close to a king in Mecca as
anyone could be in that kind of tribal
environment.
Amarbin Hisham
was the first one to kill a Muslim
for the sake of his idols and in
combat against the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam. He killed the first
Muslim was a martyr.
It was
he murdered her not only in cold blood,
but he murdered her in an incredibly
defiling way and that he took a spear.
It was actually more of a lance. It's a
short spear, harpa. And he continued to
stab her in her privates until she
passed away and was martyed. And from
that moment the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam referred to him as Abu Jah.
this man Abu Jahel is not someone
that the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
wanted as an enemy. He wanted him to
become Muslim and he tried very hard to
bring him to Islam and he made dua to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala choose the best for
the Muslims and Islam between
Hisham or Omar
and Omar
was who Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala chose
to answer that dua. And Abu Jah was
later known as the prophet Sam
said after the battle of
he said
every nation and every prophet has a
pharaoh. A pharaoh, one who acts as
Pharaoh did to Musam.
And the pharaoh of this ummah is Abu
Jahb
hishem. He said this when he was killed
in the battle of Badr by Abdullahbas.
Abu Jah antagonized the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam very much. And it
wasn't because he didn't believe he was
a prophet. No. A lot of times if we have
good intentions and as Muslims, it's
hard for us to imagine a person who
would know
that someone is a prophet or a messenger
and still harm them. And so a lot of
times we have a hard time understanding
how Abu Jahel came to the conclusions
that he did. And a lot of us may be
under the misconception
that Abu Jahel was confused. Abu Jahel
didn't understand. Abu Jahel didn't
really believe. No, he did. He believed
that he was a prophet and he said as
much in many narrations.
Iban is Muhammad Iban is he wrote a
book and it is the largest book known
up until now ever written and most
detailed on the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
it's known as Iben is unfortunately that
book has been lost
however it was summarized by a man named
Iben Hishem a great scholar
and his book is all we have left of that
book. One of the things that Iben
Hisham did was he took out all of the
chains of narration that is had so all
he says is
and so there are many narrations that
are questionable or unauthentic because
of that. However, a huge majority of his
book and a lot of what has reached us
by way of the prophet's biography and
has come by way often
is and so Iban Hisham narrates
that his narrated in his
that Iban Shurik
and Abu Sufyan both of which who were
not Muslim at the time They later
accepted Islam and Abu Jahem.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam when
he would go to pray at night
or what we know as the he would go to
thea. He would stand in front of thea
and he would place thea between himself
and
so he would face al because that was the
at the time but he would have thea in
front of him. So he would be praying to
both
simultaneously.
And this is because he always knew that
thea was the rightful of all of the
prophets and messengers. And that
praying towards
was an innovation that was introduced by
the people of the book later. However,
at the beginning of Islam, that was his
for reasons that we may discuss in
another time.
And so, the mushik
would come down
and hide around the idols
and listen to the Quran while he was
praying at night. They'd listen all
night. Abu Jah is one of them. Abu
Sufyan is one of them. andb is one of
them. And Abu Jahel was particularly
known for hiding behind the sar of
the Kaa. So he would actually stand
between the Kaa and the covering on the
Kaa so that he could listen and they
would listen to the Quran how long? All
night until fudger.
How many of us as Muslims listen to the
Quran all night? These are mushri. They
were so
taken and so enthralled by the Quran
that they would listen all night long.
On one of such occasions,
the sun started to come up and the
prophet sallallah.aii Wasallam finished
his salah and went home. And so these
three men Abu Jahb,
Abu Sufy, these are all tribe leaders.
As they were leaving, they all saw each
other on the path going home. Each one
of them asked, "What are you doing
here?" Wait, what are you doing here?
And so
They all swore by Allah to each other
and took an oath that they will never do
this again. Why? Listen to the
reasoning.
They said because if the youth of
Quraysh know that we are listening to
the Quran, it will be a fitna for them.
They're afraid for the youth, mashallah.
And so they went home. The next night,
each of them thought that the other
wasn't going to show up cuz they all
took an oath.
And they repeated the same thing again
when the sun started to rise.
They all caught each other again. What
are you doing here? You swore. you took
an oath. The youth are going to be mun
if we continue to do this. We have to,
you know, be careful with our youth,
etc. And so they again took this oath
and a third time this happened.
And as Iben mentions in his
ib decided the next morning to address
the elephant in the room.
He went to Abu Sufyan and said, "Listen,
we're let's just talk about it. We're
all listening to this book. What do you
really think about it off the record?"
He said, "I this is Abu Sufiad." He
said,
"I listen to it and there are things
that are so captivating and so true, but
then there are other things that I don't
understand about it.
I don't know." And sobb then went to Abu
Jah and asked him the same thing. And
Abu Jah said, "Why are you asking me
this? Do you think that I don't know
he's a prophet from Allah?
I know he's a messenger of Allah. But
the problem is is that us and his tribe
and the tribe of the prophet sallall.aii
said,
"We were two raceh horses in
they gave to charity and we gave."
They gave charity and we gave. They went
to war and we went to war.
They freed slaves and we freed slaves.
[Silence]
He said they continued to compete with
us in all forms of goodness until us and
Benu Hashim were on our knees at the
finish line two raceh horses neck
and neck and then suddenly they tell us
we have a prophet who Allah himself
appointed and revelation comes to him
from the heavens. How are we going to
produce a prophet now to compete with
that? Wall we will never believe in him
and we will never follow him. That is
the beginnings and the origins of Abu
Jah. The remaining verses of surah are
all about Abu Jah as the scholars of
have agreed. Inshallah we will continue
[Arabic recitation]